makes sense okay so this is kind of
what's happened after 12 months have
elapsed and then i kind of want to
continue this pattern see how it builds
on a simple compound interest idea
into something much bigger so let's have
a look at a2 this is in 2002 just to
keep the numbers easy for us
okay two things are going to happen in
the next to this
the next the space of the next 12 months
okay the first thing that happens is
we're going to take this amount right a1
and then we have a new installment right
so ten thousand dollars
goes in is that okay
just like we did in the first instance
but then a second thing happens
what gets applied to that yeah that that
interest that gets added on just like we
had here
it happens again because 12 more months
have passed so
i don't need to kind of go through this
long process i think you can see
if i just multiply by 1.08
another time that has that same effect
so 800 plus 10
000 times one thing oh yeah so let's
let's actually unpack what the the
numbers all are right
so a1 of course is this amount here so
i'm going to substitute that in
it's going to be 10 000 times 1.88
that's
a one right and then you've got another
10 000. say it again
insuring your value maturing in value
yeah absolutely it just keeps getting
better and better
yes sophie is where the square has gone
what's square so like in that in a one
1.08 because it was a power of one
ah yeah that's a really good question
you're kind of one step ahead of me so
um i've got here a one plus ten thousand
then i put this interest on right and
even though usually we like things
factorized it's nice and neat
i'm actually going to expand it to try
and clarify what sophie's talking about
see this 1.08 and this 1.08
index laws that's really the 10 000
times 1.08 squared
agree with that so this is where that
power of two
comes in okay and then i've got my other
ten thousand
how much interest has been applied to
that
think carefully that that's twos of
interest right there right
800 this is the new installment it will
be 800
because it's only one year's worth of
interest okay now where you can think
about this
conceptually is this
okay okay we're coming to that so this
is the first installment right
and it's been in there for two years
yes so that's why it's got two lots of
interest on top of it
this is the second installment
i don't know why i wrote that with a
number instead it hasn't been in there
as long
it's only been there for one year okay
now if i wanted i could fast forward all
the way to the end you can see i'm going
to go to the 20th year eventually
right and then say well that first
installment how long has it been in
there
by 2020 and the answer is it will be 20
years right however it's crucially
important
because i'm trying to establish a
pattern here right that i don't just go
straight to the end and say i know what
the answer will be okay
so you're starting to see where this is
why we are doing this after the topic we
started
at the beginning of the week we're going
to do one more why do you think i'm
going to a3
why do you think that's enough i always
need three to establish a pattern
whether it's like an
ap or a gp you're you're probably
guessing which one it's going to be in a
second
do i do all this working in the exam the
short answer is
yes because where does this i'm going to
have some results at the end here right
where do they come from
there's going to be like several marks
worth of working here right and then
apply the pattern to the precisely so
i'm forming a pattern here that i can
use
to answer these questions okay all right
let's just do it one more time
um where does a3 come from well you had
the previous year's
stuff this is all a2 right do you agree
you had a new installment on
like so and then one other thing happens
you don't just put money in time passes
so you multiply by 1.08
that's the interest okay so every time
installment
interest installment interest from here
i'm going to go straight to an expanded
line because i think i know what's going
on here right
everything here in the previous line
i'll write this down then i'll come to
your question
everything here in the previous line
gets a new lot of interest and then the
most
recent installment which isn't in this
line it also gets its interest is that
okay
so we'll drop that down and then serena
will come to your question
actually i might as well because i think
i'm okay to write this down while
listening to you
what did you want to ask or suggest so
you said a1 plus 10
so you're saying a1 as the first line of
work at the top the second line
these are both a1 yeah
substitute it in yeah put that over
there into here and then you
in that line you expanded to the
expanded form instead of running
and you did the same thing for a3 yeah i
keep on i keep on building it the reason
why i've done this
is so you can see every year the same
thing is happening yeah
say it again it's exactly like a
polynomial
okay so there's a one there and then it
expands out so you can see
this is what i'm going to put into a2
there it is that's where these guys come
from look there's the first installments
been in there for three years
so it's got three lots of interest
there's the second installment been
there for two years so it's got two's
interest you get the idea
okay all right three down
so i feel confident now to be able to
say well after 20 years
in 2020 like dot dot dot time passes i'm
not going to do this another 17 times
i think i've established a pattern here
i'm going to say in 2020
a 20 will equal okay now look carefully
at your indices because sometimes they
are different depending on how you build
this right
you've got this first ten thousand
dollars that you put in right at the
beginning or
that they did right how many times we
applied interest to it
look really carefully here's 2003 the
line before this is why i went to the
effort of establishing a patent right
see this index here matches the number
of years it's been in there
right so therefore this first one it's
got 20
years worth of interest applied to it
does that make sense
okay and then the next one it's been in
there for one year
less than that so it'll be this guy will
be 19 years
worth of interest i'll do one more to
get my three
1.08 to power 18. that's this guy
but then i have all these other ones
that i didn't bother writing every
single line because it would be taking
forever
okay but i will get one final one at the
end
and just like i wonder if i can
highlight it here
just like every year previous right the
last term you write down
here here
and here it's always the most recent
installment
which had one lot of interest added onto
it does that make sense
yeah in short
exactly right so this is the reason why
i put this pattern here right
a 20 would be the previous year's a19
plus your installment multiplied by your
interest okay
you notice that i don't have like some
say it this way even though it's strange
something like naked 10 000 at the end
that's added on with no interest applied
to it
why it's because of this where did i
write it it's because this date
right you see that i've gone all the way
to the 30th of june
so that's why my interest for the whole
gets applied and there's no ten thousand
dollars sitting there that i've just put
in
that hasn't had the time to develop
interest make sense